[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir à toutes et à tous
heureux de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle semaine de sens public votre
émission de débat de reportage et
d'expertise sur Public Sénat en étant
centre pendant 90 minutes avec deux
grands thèmes comme tous les soirs la
réforme des retraites peut-elle devenir
le boulet du second quinquennat Macron
après le 49-3 après les motion de
censure qu'elle marge de manœuvre pour
l'exécutif remaniement dissolution
retrait du texte quelles options sont
encore sur la table est-ce une crise de
régime qui sont les gagnants les
perdants de cette séquence politique
réponse dans une minute et puis pour
notre second débat direction
l'Afghanistan sous le jou des talibans
depuis juillet 2021 les femmes voient
leur liberté disparaître les unes après
les autres en décembre c'était les
universités qui leur permet la porte sur
ordre du régime
que nous avions était d'aller à
l'université vitamine nos études de
devenir un bon médecin et de servir
notre société mais ils nous ont pris
cela aussi
le désespoir des Afghans ce sera dans 45
minutes notre second débat mais d'abord
donc après l'utilisation du 49-3 peut-on
parler de crise politique ou même de
crise de régime première réponse Jérôme
Rabier
contraint au 49-3 faute de détenir une
majorité à l'Assemblée et porteur d'une
réforme des retraites impopulaire
l'exécutif va maintenant devoir préparer
l'après et pour tenir encore un peu plus
de 4 ans Emmanuel Macron sera contraint
de se renouveler quatre ans sur ce
régime là ça me semble être enfin à
sacerdoce impossible à tenir il va
devoir un petit peu ce qu'on avait
assisté après le mouvement des gilets
jaunes créé
une sorte d'électrochoc dans la vie
démocratique le gouvernement pourrait
aussi ne pas survivre à cette séquence
politique mais pour ce chercheur au CNRS
ce n'est même plus une question de
personnes mais de principe contrairement
à leur espoir de
signifier aux Français résignez-vous
parce que je ne céderai pas en fait
chaque étape franchie renforce la colère
renforce l'opposition à la réforme donc
on est typiquement vraiment dans une
dynamique d'escalade et la seule façon
d'obtenir une désescalade c'est de
retirer le projet les républicains de
leur côté sont bien au centre du jeu
mais divisés la cacophonie des
différents courants qui traversent la
droite rendant difficilement lisible
leur ligne politique aujourd'hui pour
les LR il y a un enjeu de survie
politique
survie politique qui peut être peut-être
réussie si un la question du leadership
est réglée dans cette famille politique
et certainement pas ce qu'on observe
aujourd'hui cette confusion ambiguïtée
entre les LR au Sénat et les LR à
l'Assemblée nationale si la gauche de
son côté espère reprendre des couleurs
dans la bataille c'est bien sur les
bancs du RN qu'on peut le plus espérer
de ce moment politique si les autres
ne trouvent pas un moyen d'action sur
les dynamiques à l'oeuvre elle sera la
gagnante naturelle marine Le Pen n'a
rien à faire pour récolter les voies
puisque la dynamique est déjà en place
chaque camp espère profiter de l’après
réforme pour rebondir ou progresser sans
savoir pour l'instant si les Français
devront prochainement les départager
dans les yeux
[Musique]
président de cohabitation on a vu que
dans le passé ça réussissait assez bien
à d'autres il peut ce qui est sa
stratégie avoir une stratégie
d'attentismes d'usure en se disant au
fond dans le passé toutes les réformes
des retraites ont été un populaire et
puis la protestation qui parfois était
très forte c'est peu à peu étioler bon
ça sera pas facile parce que là on
arrive à un degré de colère qui est
phénoménal il lui reste ce qui avait
fait Chirac la possibilité de retirer le
projet et le projet une fois voté pour
le CP voilà il l'avait fait pour le CPE
il lui reste le recours au référendum
donc vous voyez il a une panoplie
d'armes qui lui permet encore d'exister
politique mais on en détaillera
évidemment plusieurs de ces de ces armes
ou de ses de ses hypothèses de ces
options leur Salvat il y a une majorité
de Français qui espèrent voir tomber ce
gouvernement et surtout cette réforme ne
pas s'appliquer parce qu'elle Perrineau
parlait de la violence est-ce que vous
quand vous sondez l'opinion vous voyez
une violence qui est en forme ascendante
là en tout cas c'est vrai que Pascal
Perrineau parlait de colère c'est le
premier mot qui vient à l'état d'esprit
des français quand il pense à cette
réforme des retraites effectivement je
crois que pendant toute la séquence de
cette réforme du de l'annonce de la mise
en place de la réforme des débats qui a
pu avoir etc on a vu cette colère en
tout cas qui ne qui ne s'étiolait pas au
contraire là aujourd'hui elle est
extrêmement forte et je dirais
après le après l'addition du 49-3 jours
il y a un regain très clair mais j'ai
envie de dire qu'il y avait un une
colère qui était présente dans l'opinion
depuis longtemps en fait on a
l'impression que le président et le
gouvernement actuel on fait comme si
2017-2022 il s'était rien passé or il
s'est passé énormément de choses il
s'est passé les gilets jaunes il s'est
passé la guerre en Ukraine le covid etc
et puis c'est passé aussi ce qui s'est
passé à l'Assemblée nationale
c'est-à-dire des élections qui ont pas
donné une franche majorité au président
et qui quelque part était un message
pour dire nous souhaitons un comment
dire un gouvernement un peu une façon de
gouvernée différente avec davantage de
compromis avec davantage de discussions
entre entre parlementaires et c'est pas
du tout ce qu'on a eu et je pense que la
colère est de plus en plus forte
aujourd'hui et le risque c'est justement
c'est que cette réforme des retraites
quelque part elle soit prise un peu
comme prétexte pour aller au bout de
d'une contestation très forte de
l'opinion Pierre Jacques est-ce que vous
vous parlez de crise de régime ce soir
en tout cas je pense que aujourd'hui il
y a une forme d'exacerbation du
caractère obsolète de nos institutions
le recours au 44 de le recours au 44 3
puis le 49.3 l'article 8 qu'on découvre
du Règlement du Sénat vous voyez ce sont
des instruments institutionnels qui sont
tout à fait légaux qui sont inscrits
dans le caractère de la Constitution la
question de la légitimité de ces de ces
articles est posé aujourd'hui c'est
d'ailleurs tout l'objet des débats c'est
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui compte tenu de la
très forte mobilisation de l'opposition
majeure à l'Assemblée nationale oui
parce que visiblement il y avait pas de
majorité pour ce texte puisque le
gouvernement 3 plus l'absence de
majorité qui se dessine à l'Assemblée
nationale pose la question effectivement
de nos institutions donc en ce sens oui
on pourrait parler de crise de régime
parce que on arrive à un essoufflement
nos institutions un essoufflement des
institutions parce qu'aujourd'hui parce
que le périnolo disait il reste des
solutions des outils pour Emmanuel
Macron il y a la dissolution il y a le
recours au référendum il y a la
possibilité pour lui de nouer de
nouvelles majorités peut-être avec la
droite qui semble aujourd'hui peut-être
hésitante à rejoindre ça va pas bien
marché mais bon ça peut être nous
disions aujourd'hui mais les trois
visiblement c'est pas les options
qu'Emmanuel Macron a décidé de
privilégier donc oui je pense qu'il y a
de cette dans dans ce que l'on vit en ce
moment une crise institutionnelle forte
qui devrait dire à nous interroger sur
nos institutions Emmanuel Macron le
premier d'ailleurs avait promis un
renouvellement institutionnel et il ne
l'a pas fait donc je pense que si ce
n'est pas une crise de régime c'est au
moins une crise institutionnelle et
évidemment là tous les regards se
tournent vers Emmanuel Macron on se dit
est-ce qu'il va y avoir une prise de
parole dans les dans les prochaines
heures dans les prochains jours Matthieu
alors je doute pas que vous soyez très
bien informé là-dessus mais peut-il
faire autrement d'une certaine façon
d'abord il y a que lui qui le sait oui
on a eu un semblant de prise de parole
hier avec un message transmis au
rédaction et notamment à l'AFP le
Président il explique ça devait y
apporter son soutien aux présidents de
l'Assemblée à la Présidence de
l'Assemblée nationale et au président du
Sénat le soutien aux élus qui ont été
menacés ce week-end et puis il exprimait
sa volonté de voir cette réforme
poursuivre son cheminement démocratique
jusqu'au bout et même une expression qui
interroge parce que oui la Constitution
était respectée oui mais peut-on parler
vraiment de démocratie et ce qui est un
esprit démocratique qui a soufflé sur
cette réforme difficile à être difficile
à dire difficile de
quelque chose que l'on a entendu
aujourd'hui il y a besoin d'une parole
présidentielle assez forte pour qu'on
comprenne où il en est
et d'ailleurs elle est pardon elle est
très attendue cette parler français
présidentielle par les Français il y a
plus de 7 Français sur 10 qui a tant
d'effectivement Emmanuel Macron parle et
même plus de 80 % de ses propres
électeurs c'est à dire que même ces
électeurs ils sont un petit peu chahutés
là aujourd'hui
il continue à le soutenir et notamment
sur la réforme des retraites mais plus
la contestation est forte et plus son
socle de se fragilise en fait de fait
alors dans ce débat on essaye de
d'évaluer les finalement les séquelles
de de cette séquence politique tout le
monde emploie cette expression depuis
quelques jours moi aussi ben voilà je
suis tombé dedans mais Pascal Perrineau
je lisais dans Libération
cette tribune de Serge Julie qui dit
c'est l'agonie du macronisme on est en
train de d'assister c'est un peu
imprudent à mon avis de parler et agonie
du macronisme parce que si vous le
macronisme qu'est-ce que c'est à part
Emmanuel Macron aurait Emmanuel Macron
il est toujours bien là le macronisme il
est affaibli depuis extrêmement
longtemps et au fond une des raisons des
difficultés du Président c'est
qu'au-delà de sa propre personne il n'a
jamais su porter véritablement ce qu'est
le macronisme en développant d'abord un
parti digne de ce nom Renaissance n'est
pas un parti digne de ce nom en
développant un réseau des lieux locaux
qui seraient autant d'abord
d'amortisseurs avec la société française
mais aussi d'instances d'explication il
n'y a pas de grands élus locaux du
macronisme ou quelques rallier ça c'est
la deuxième le deuxième la deuxième
faiblesse du macronisme et puis même
vous regardez le gouvernement
vous regardez l'entourage à l'Elysée
quels sont sans être désagréables les
grandes pointures les grandes pointures
c'est des rallier qui viennent en
général d'ailleurs plutôt de LR comme
Bruno Le Maire comme Gérald de Darmanin
mais le macronisme n'a pas su
inventé enfanter la fameuse nouvelle
politique dont il nous parlait il disait
voilà la vieille politique à tous les
défauts ok très bien prenons acte et il
y avait d'énormes attentes par rapport à
cette nouvelle politique mais cette
nouvelle politique de qu'est-ce qu'elle
a produit et c'est ça qui fait
qu'aujourd'hui on a affaire un président
qui est un président très isolé dont les
Français en effet attendent la parole
mais avec un espace public qui est
devenu très périlleux parce que entre ce
président auquel on prête tous les
pouvoirs et qui ne les a pas et des
citoyens complètement isolés et très en
colère il n'y a plus aucun amortisseur
et ça personnellement quand vous
regardez ça dans l'histoire c'est
dangereux
c'est intéressant parce que ça ça me
fait réagir à la question que vous
posiez avant sur la fin de régime ou pas
de fin de régime parce que ça cette
fonction présidentielle est aussi au
centre des interrogations c'est à dire
qu'on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui on a un
président de la République qui décide
d'à peu près tout c'est lui qui dit au
gouvernement je vous donne
l'autorisation de faire 49-3 parce que
j'ai considéré que les marchés
financiers que parce que Bruxelles peut
que parce que pour toutes les raisons
qui sont les siennes il faut avancer
mettre de manière ferme et sur cette
réforme donc je fais passer cette
réforme donc je vais parler de crise
c'est aussi oui mais c'est pas très
nouveau alors au moins particulièrement
depuis le quinquennat elle est quand
même particulièrement exacerbée sous
Emmanuel Macron et elle est d'autant
plus exacerbée que vous avez bien vu que
le dialogue social qui est une tradition
dans notre pays on dit toujours que ça
fonctionne pas il y a quand même 40 70 %
des accords d'entreprise qui sont signés
dans notre pays donc ça veut dire qu'il
y a quand même du dialogue dans des
entreprises mais le dialogue social au
niveau gouvernement gouvernemental n'a
pas fonctionné le dialogue social le
dialogue pardon parlementaire n'a pas
fonctionné et c'est pas la première loi
où ça se passe dans ces termes-là donc
ce que je veux dire c'est que le
macronisme c'est aussi une incarnation
puissance 10 peut-être que par rapport à
le passé de cette présidentialisation
présidentielle de notre régime politique
alors on enregistre cette émission à
l'heure où l'émotion de censure ont été
déposées mais sans avoir le résultat du
vote je suis transpar avec vous en
revanche la première ministre a pris la
parole pour dénoncer l'anti
parlementarisme à l'oeuvre des
oppositions on écoute Elisabeth borne
cet après-midi
après intervention j'ai constaté en
écoutant certains orateurs qu'il n'y a
décidément pas de limite à la duplicité
ce sont les mêmes qui ont tout fait pour
saboter le débat à coup d'amendement
dilatoire de cris et d'insultes qui
viennent nous reprocher de ne pas avoir
pu suffisamment débattre
ce sont des élus de la nation qui
viennent nous expliquer sans vergogne
que 175 heures de séances plus que pour
les deux précédentes réforme des
retraites ne valent rien ce sont des
députés qui déni son rôle au Parlement
et affirme que la rue est plus légitime
que les institutions
on essaye de se projeter un peu et de
voir quelle est la le poids après elle
peut être le poids politique des uns et
des autres dans les dans les jours dans
les semaines et dans les mois qui
viennent donc focus sur Elizabeth borne
évidemment vous me voyez venir leur
Salvat sa popularité elle est elle est
très faible on sait que le premier
ministre est souvent le fusible de la
Cinquième République comment vous
évaluez sa capacité de peser dans les
prochaines semaines c'est vrai que même
elle elle l'a dit
dernière qu'elle avait tout à fait
conscience effectivement de son rôle de
fusible c'est vrai que là il y a une
très grosse majorité de Français qui
soient très qu'elle soit débit de ses
fonctions et donc qu'il y ait une
nouvelle ou un nouveau Premier ministre
avant même de parler de dissolution de
l'Assemblée nationale mais en tout cas
effectivement je crois que ça va être
difficile pour elle et on a bien
conscience de continuer et y compris
d'ailleurs pour Emmanuel Macron de
gouverner le pays dans cette situation
parce que
a priori le texte va passer
la réforme va être appliquée ou pas
alors c'est vrai que Emmanuel Macron a
encore quelques armes à sa disposition
mais en tout cas si elle est appliquée
qu'elle soit appliquée ou pas d'ailleurs
j'ai envie de dire je pense que ce sera
très très compliqué de gouverner dans
les prochains mois parce que il y a
quand même cette colère justement de
l'opinion qui ne qui ne qui va pas
s'effriter là je pense qu'il y a un
moment donné il y a encore quelques
semaines on pouvait dire ça va se tasser
etc là franchement on arrive à un point
où je pense que ce sera très difficile
ça se tasse mais qu'est-ce que vous
retenez des autres interventions là on a
entendu Elisabeth borne c'est vrai
qu'elle était la cible de d'à peu près
toutes les attaques d'abord un mot sur
Elisabeth parce que ça fait partie de la
définition du macronisme on a vu que
tout au cours de son mandat et de son
quinquennat précédent il a toujours eu
un problème de renouvellement ou en tout
cas de remaniement à chaque fois ça
prend du temps et puis il finit par
nommer des technocrates des énarques
domptés et aujourd'hui
issus Elizabeth borne c'est une c'est
une énarque qui a fait toute sa carrière
dans la haute fonction à la mairie de
Paris à la RATP et on peut se dire quand
même que on a la à la tête de l'État un
président de la République et une
première ministre qui sont un peu
éloignés Emmanuel Macron n'a pas
d'expérience de mandat d'un mandat local
et ils avaient de borne elle vient tout
juste elle a tout juste été élu député
on peut pas dire qu'elle est
l'expérience de terrain de de
confrontation aussi avec le peuple et
que et que ce qui ressort aussi beaucoup
de cette période c'est cette déconnexion
entre un peuple qui dit warning ça va
pas et ça va pas ni la méthode ni le
contenu des réformes qui sont proposées
et un gouvernement un président qui
s'entête ensuite pour répondre à la
question sur les interventions parce
qu'il y a quand même eu des
interventions que j'ai trouvé assez
forte quand même d'abord Aurore Berger a
fait un discours que j'ai trouvé très
agressif à l'égard de ce qui est le rêve
de la députés Renaissance qui qui est
peut-être quand même l'une des
meilleures politiques je dis qu'il y a
beaucoup de techno chez les macronisme
mais elle pour la peine elle fait de la
politique la cohérence d'Aurore berger
on peut l'interroger parce que quand on
voit son parcours politique elle est
quand même passer elle a dénoncé ceux
qui étaient des filles unistes par le
passé dans les républicains qui ne
votent pas la réforme aujourd'hui mais
je trouve qu'elle a eu un il y a eu
quelque chose de très agressif à l'égard
des oppositions le reprochant
aujourd'hui aux oppositions de faire le
jeu du rassemblement national mais là je
trouve que c'est quand même un tout
petit peu gonflé quand on est issu d'une
majorité qui en l'espace d'un
quinquennat et un an de quinquennat a
fait progresser le Front national le
rassemblement national de 3 millions de
voix donc là je trouve que les leçons
qui sont données par Robert j'ai été un
tout petit peu alors pas hors contexte
franchement hors contexte je vous
interrompre parce qu'on y reviendra sur
le rassemblement national mais je
voudrais qu'on reparle du 49-3 avec vous
Mathieu émotion de censure d'aujourd'hui
évidemment il y a des conséquences de la
suite logique du 49-3 les 7 articles on
va parler des séquelles d'une certaine
façon c'est comme des répliques d'un
séisme ça n'a pas fini on n'a pas fini
de les ressentir oui car même si
l'article 49-3 de la Constitution a été
déjà été employée 100 fois depuis le
début de la 5e République les
circonstances particulières et la nature
du projet de loi pour lequel il a été
utilisé fond de celui-là vous l'avez dit
un petit séisme dont on risque de
mesurer les répliques pendant un certain
temps sur l'échiquier politique d'abord
parce que dans cette assemblée sans
majorité absolue mais 49-3 et signe à la
fois l'échec d'une méthode et la fin
d'un rêve celui de la concertation du
consensus et des coalitions de projet en
tout cas pour pour l'instant c'est vrai
quoi bon prendre le risque de s'allier
ou de se compromettre avec ce pouvoir si
c'est pour que cela se finisse avec un
passage en force à quoi bon prendre le
risque d'afficher au grand jour ses
divisions internes comme l'ont fait les
républicains si au final le 49-3 permet
de faire adopter les textes sans se
mouiller au final ça les arrange on voit
bien que ça pose des questions dans la
majorité aussi l'affaire va laisser des
traces car les députés du camp
présidentiel sont dépités si j'ose dire
ce qu'on mouille la chemise pour tenter
de de convaincre ou d'amander ce qu'on
croisait le faire qui sont pris des
coups ceux qu'on risque et des
invectives ou des reproches sur les
marchés mais tout cela en sont pour
leurs frais les voilà complices d'un
gouvernement autoritaire et brutal au
plus grand bonheur de leurs accusateurs
d'hier et d'aujourd'hui la France
insoumise ou le rassemblement national
qui n'en demandait pas tant alors il y a
aussi le champ social et on peut dire
que là aussi les conséquences seront de
longue durée oui parce que ce vice
démocratique selon les mots de Laurent
Berger aura eu un double effet au fond
sur l'inter syndicale d'abord celui de
resserrer les rangs en fournissant un AR
à tous ceux qui voulaient rester
mobilisés alors on verra bien si le
conflit s'enlise mais voir tous les
syndicats y compris les plus légalistes
comme la CFDT continue à contester un
projet de loi après que celui-ci a été
adopté nos rien de bon pour l'exécutif
la porte de sortie du mouvement risque
d'être très très compliqué à trouver le
second effet c'est qu'on voit mal les
syndicats à revenir de cistaux s'asseoir
à une table au gouvernementale pour
discuter des autres chantiers qui ont
été lancés que vont devenir par exemple
la future loi travail la réforme de
l'éducation nationale celle de notre
système de santé si elles se font sans
voir contre les partenaires sociaux
Emmanuel Macron qui misait beaucoup sur
son conseil national de droit de la
refondation qui était déjà boycoté par
une partie des organisations syndicales
va avoir du mal à convaincre là pour le
coup qu'il a encore changé et puis il y
a les conséquences dans l'opinion
publique chez les Français oui et c'est
à mes yeux un des effets les plus
délétères car moins peut-être moins
visibles mais peut-être plus profond
plus durable le 49-3 a apporté de l'eau
au moulin de tous ceux qui s'estiment
mal écouté mal représentés mal gouverné
à tous ceux qui qu'il est devenu
impossible de se faire entendre sans
renverser la table à tous ceux qui font
le choix par dépit ou par des goûts de
se mettre hors-jeu de la vie citoyenne
ou à tous ceux qui considèrent que
lorsqu'une démocratie tombe malade et
bien il vaut mieux l'acheter plutôt que
de la soigner alors pour tout cela le
recours au 49-3 transformer ce qui est
une crise politique et sociale en une
crise alors peut-être pas de régime mais
au moins institutionnel et je vous
rejoins puis avec moi et ça c'est
beaucoup plus complexe évidemment à
régler merci Mathieu est-ce que ce là
reste sur le 49-3 alors ça va est-ce que
effectivement c'est peut-être difficile
à évaluer mais parce que il y a beaucoup
de Français qui qui connaissaient pas
son utilisation mais maintenant c'est
voilà on peut dire que c'est bien
partager par tout le monde est-ce que
les séquelles de de ce qui est présenté
comme un passage en force peuvent être
durables dans l'opinion alors si on en
croit une étude qui a été réalisée
justement par Sylvie Sylvain Brouard à
Sciences Po donc il y a eu plusieurs
études qui ont été réalisées je crois
entre 2009 et 2017 me semble-t-il sur
les dates et effectivement quand on voit
que quand il y a eu des utilisations de
49-3 l'impasse sur l'opinion est très
important et surtout durable et je crois
que c'est ça qui est important à retenir
c'est effectivement cette durabilité et
alors c'est d'autant plus le cas quand
on a le sentiment ou quand l'opinion a
le sentiment en plus il n'y a pas
d'obstruction majeure si vous voulez
qu'il n'y a pas de d'accumulation
là comme c'est le cas en ce moment donc
effectivement dans l'opinion ça risque
d'être très fort puis je reparlerai
aussi de d'Emmanuel Macron par rapport à
ce 49-3 c'est à dire que moi ce qui
m'avait marqué quand Emmanuel Macron a
pris quelques quelques mois d'exercice
de son premier mandat c'était dans
l'opinion quand on entendait Emmanuel
Macron nous méprise et puis il y a eu
les gilets jaunes juste après etc et en
fait on a l'impression que ce mépris
s'étend pas seulement finalement à la
population mais aux corps intermédiaires
au syndicat à la vie parlementaire et
c'est là où effectivement ça va être
très difficile de remonter quelque part
et bien voilà on crie au vice
démocratique au déni démocratique etc
donc là il y a eu certainement une
erreur d'évaluation mais ce qu'il faut
pour autant supprimer cet article non je
ne crois pas je ne crois pas parce que
vous savez il avait été inventé en 1958
il faisait l'objet d'un soutien général
des forces politiques sauf le Parti
communiste Guy Mollet par exemple et les
socialistes étaient tout à fait d'accord
parce que c'était considéré comme une
arme qui permettait de sortir du chaos
gouvernemental de la Quatrième
République voilà et de rationaliser en
effet les effets pervers de d'un régime
parlementaire qui avait perdu le cap
souvenons-nous sous la Quatrième
République même 24 gouvernements 10 ans
c'est à dire c'est pas une ambition non
plus voilà et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
paradoxalement avec ce qui s'est passé
au législatif de juin 2022 c'est-à-dire
l'utilisation par les Français des
élections législatives comme si votaient
un peu à la proportionnelle on revient
un peu à la Quatrième République
regardez ce qui se passe c'est même
assez troublant
il y a le rôle du parti charnière
l'iotte qui connaît ses liotte et ça va
être de députés qui a encore quelques
jours à peu près à peu près personne et
Elliott selon qu'il tombe de ce côté ou
d'un autre et bien fait la décision
c'était le cas sous la Quatrième
République c'était les petits partis
charnières selon qu'il tombait à droite
à gauche ou ailleurs faisait et des
faisait bien sûr les les majorités
d'autre part des gouvernements qui sont
des gouvernements parfois de coalition
qui ne tiennent pas
les forces il faut bien reconnaître qui
sont qui ont voté pour la motion de
censure ces forces c'est des forces mais
tout à fait capable de dire non et dire
non à la réforme des retraites incapable
de mettre en oeuvre un gouvernement de
substitution vous voyez pas monsieur de
Courson avec Madame Mathilde panot et
Marine Le Pen voilà que ferait-il ils
ont à peu près rien à partager donc il
n'y a pas d'alternative ce qui rend
d'ailleurs les Français inquiets parce
que les Français sont en colère mais ils
sont inquiets sur la suite et on peut
l'être objectivement parce que si le
macronisme à terme est rejeté quelle est
la coalition même après des législatives
quelle est la coalition capable de
dégager une majorité de gouvernement
aujourd'hui aucune force politique n'est
capable de cela et d'ailleurs pierre
Jacquemin on pourrait penser que la
gauche ou Lego sorte renforcée de de
voilà de la semaine et de la semaine
passée
est-ce que vous dites ça ou est-ce que
vous êtes moins une petite rectification
parce que je disais tout à l'heure en
parlant de la première ministre qu'elle
était
en arc elle est bien au fonctionnaire
mais elle est polytechniciennes
je crois aujourd'hui montre sa
déconnexion vis-à-vis de la pour
répondre à votre question je pense qu'on
a une gauche qui aujourd'hui existe sur
la gauche moi il y a quelque chose c'est
pas pour d'aller sur le débat d'après
qui se trouve sans doute celui du
rassemblement national mais j'entends ce
récit assez inanimiste parmi les
confrères et dans les médias d'une
manière générale pour dire que la
séquence est formidable pour Marine Le
Pen parce que serait la plus
républicaine sera et il y a une espèce
de prophétie auto-réalisatrice qui est
en train de se mettre en oeuvre autour
du rassemblement national qui aurait eu
la meilleure séquence du moment et notre
métier notre travail de journaliste est
justement et déconstruire ce genre de
choses parce que vous voyez ce qui a été
fait d'ailleurs ça a été rappelé par
Robert gale son message mais le RN a été
absent de tout ce débat parlementaire
elle intervient en disant qu'est-ce
qu'avez-vous fait des trois derniers
mois et c'est vrai que la question peut
se poser et quelle est la proposition du
rassemblement national sur les questions
sociales sur les questions de retraite
qui manque quand même de clarté diviter
donc d'abord un faut remettre les choses
dans l'ordre sur ce café le
rassemblement national ensuite la gauche
la gauche les syndicats je pense ce sont
les grands vainqueurs je pense de cette
séquence parce que je crois que on peut
leur avoir reproché plein de choses par
le passé là ils ont montré la
possibilité d'abord de nouer des liens
entre syndicats qui sont pas forcément
d'accord sur tout le la CGT la CFDT ont
quand même bien avancé ensemble ils ont
organisé sont qui se sont bien pas du
tout d'accord avec la stratégie de la
nuque et notamment de LFI à l'Assemblée
en revanche bon
la stratégie des accords c'est une chose
maintenant il faut quand même pas sous
pas être il faut se souvenir quand même
la nuit pèse c'est constituée autour
d'un projet de gouvernement qui a mis
tout le monde d'accord c'est quand même
le plus important c'est qu'a priori il y
a un accord de gouvernement qui avait
été qui a été scellé en juin dernier sur
les stratégies des uns les autres bon ça
c'est sûr que bon vous avez pas la même
tradition du côté de la France insoumise
que du côté des socialistes ou des
écologistes c'est pareil d'ailleurs chez
les syndicats la tradition du la CGT
n'est pas la même que la CFDT mais ça
n'empêche qu'ils avancent ensemble donc
oui la gauche est peut-être pas à la
gauche parlementaire n'est peut-être pas
celle qui s'en sort la plus grande cette
séquence parce que peut-être ne
s'est-elle pas fait suffisamment
entendre ou en tout cas de n’êtes pas
suffisamment entendu quelle était sa
proposition alternative maintenant si
demain il y a des élections législatives
je pense que le débat qui sera celui
d'une clarté sur quel est le projet sur
les retraites quel est le projet social
quel est le projet économique des uns
des autres sera davantage peut-être
écouté par les Français et peut-être
prendre-t-il feront-ils le choix en
conscience d'un projet de gouvernement
Mathieu hameau ensuite on écoute marine
de la gauche parlementaire on retiendra
ses excès parce que ça a été marqué dans
les débats parlementaires par des
invectives par des insultes par donc
voilà on a tendance à à retenir les
excès on retiendra une forme de travail
parlementaire il y en a eu je pense au
député Jérôme Guedj qui a eu l'idée
d'aller consulter la Direction de la
Sécurité sociale pour avoir les comptes
et les bases sur lesquels c'était fixé
le ministre pour pour faire sa réforme
après j'ai une grosse interrogation pour
ce qu'on a pas retenu à mes yeux de
contre-projet et bon la bonne raison
qu'il n'était pas d'accord sur ce
contre-projet oui il y a la retraite à
60 ans elle retourne 37 années dans le
programme de la France insoumise oui les
socialistes et les écologistes la corde
autour du cou ont signé qu'ils étaient
d'accord en juin dernier mais personne
ne la défendu ça n'a même pas imprimé
dans ni lors de la campagne de
législatives de juin 2022 alors que
c'était contre la réforme à 65 ans
prenait par Emmanuel Macron je ne vois
pas pourquoi ça engrangerait davantage
aujourd'hui alors on va écouter puisque
elle elle se dit on se posait la
question de de d'une dissolution
législative évidemment et Marine Le Pen
quand on lui pose la question je suis
prête à prendre le pouvoir
je n'ai absolument pas peur du pouvoir
je l'attends avec impatience voilà je
l'attends avec impatience pour pouvoir
démontrer au français que nous sommes
capables de porter les réformes qu'ils
attendent et que nous pouvons obtenir
dans des délais relativement bref des
très bons résultats pour le pays et pour
eux pour leur sécurité pour leur
prospérité et pour la défense de leur
identité alors le rassemblement national
qui tire profit de cette séquence
politique dit prophétie
auto-réalisatrice et vous dans les
enquêtes d'opinion c'est un peu qui
gagne mais auprès de qui c'est-à-dire
quand on demande aux Français qui
s'organisent de cette séquence bien
effectivement c'est Marine Le Pen qui
arrive en première position
non c'est Marine Le Pen qui arrive en
première tous les sondages ne racontent
pas la même histoire alors en fait si on
détaille par individu c'est Marine Le
Pen voilà c'est Marine Le Pen puis les
syndicats mais ceci dit en termes
d'image également des partis politiques
c'est le seul qui gagne en images dans
cette séquence par rapport à tous les
autres partis et y compris par rapport
au syndicat c'est vrai que les syndicats
remontent mais aussi ils étaient très
bas c'est-à-dire qu'on les voyait plus
depuis des années on leur faisait plus
confiance on considérait qu'il ne
représentait pas suffisamment à la
population donc là ils sont en train de
monter ils ont fait un bon spectaculaire
mais aux yeux de l'opinion celle qui
restent la grande gagnante c'est
effectivement le rassemblement national
et c'est effectivement Marine Le Pen et
alors j'ajouterai quelque chose qui est
très intéressant je trouve dans la
séquence actuelle c'est Jordan Bardella
qui a quelque part franchi un peu une
frontière jusqu'à lors jamais franchie
en disant ce week-end si les députés LR
effectivement vote la motion de censure
dans ce cas là nous ne présenterons pas
de candidats en cas de dissolution de
l'Assemblée nationale et ça c'est
quelque chose pour moi de majeur dans la
vie politique française c'est à dire que
là vraiment il y a quelque chose enfin
un univers complètement nouveau qui
s'ouvre dans la vie politique
c'est énorme c'est énorme cette affaire
parce que ça rend le rassemblement
national qui en dépit des déclarations
de Marine Le Pen n'a pas à lui seul de
capacité majoritaire ça rend en cas
d'alliance avec tout ou partie des
républicains ça rend là une possibilité
véritablement d'alternance avec une
majorité qui aurait voilà un allié
constitué enraciné dans le territoire à
savoir les députés républicains donc
c'est très important là on verra ce
qu'il l'emporte dans cet appareil
extrêmement clivé qui est devenu parti
républicain entre j'allais dire ceux on
le voit ceux qui sont tentés
particulièrement dans certaines terres
que ce soit le nord ou le sud là les
républicains si vous la concurrence avec
le RN c'est une réalité et donc ils
peuvent être séduits par un appel du
pied et puis de l'autre côté Rachida
Dati qui elle fait le porte-voix de
Nicolas Sarkozy et appelle à un soutien
à un gouvernement de type macronien donc
qu'est-ce qu'il l'emportera pour
l'instant on va continuer vous savez
encore pendant quelques semaines et
peut-être même quelques mois le décompte
qui va avec qui au parti républicain je
propose à Steve Jourdain de nous
rejoindre tout de suite pour parler de
la suite on continue de se projeter bon
soit Steve bienvenue on a beaucoup
entendu ces derniers jours après le 49-3
c'est plié la réforme va s'appliquer
qu'est-ce qu'on peut en dire pas
forcément pas forcément Thomas une loi
adopter par le Parlement n'est pas
toujours appliqué on a un peu tendance à
l'oublier mais avant qu'un texte se
traduise concrètement sur le terrain il
faut plusieurs étapes il doit être
publié au Journal officiel pour cela il
faut que la loi soit promulguée par le
Président de la République dans les 15
jours suivant son adoption et même et
même après la promulgation pour qu'une
loi fonctionne réellement il faut
prendre des décrets d'applications sans
décret pas d'exécution sans exécution
pas de loi Thomas donc Emmanuel Macron a
15 jours pour promulguer le texte que
peut-il se passer dans dans ce temps le
Conseil constitue constitutionnel peut
entrer en piste et faire dérailler la
réforme pour cela les oppositions
doivent le saisir afin de contester
l'ensemble de la loi ou certaines de ces
dispositions pour ça il faut réunir 60
députés ou 60 sénateurs a priori ça
devrait pas trop proposer de problème le
Conseil constitutionnel devrait bien
être saisi dans les prochains jours et
le député liotte Charles de Courson
fourmis ses arguments et de conteste la
loi à la fois sur la forme et sur le
fond écoutez-le je pense que le Conseil
conditionnel aura
à trancher de questions fondamentales
est-ce que le recours à une loi de
financement rectifiative sur les social
pour faire une réforme de retraite 15
jours après avoir adopté la loi de
finances la loi de financement initiale
si je peux dire est-ce que c'est pas un
détournement complet de procédure prenez
par exemple le fameux article 2 sur
l'index senior tout le monde sait il va
sauter voilà notez que pendant son
examen par le Conseil constitutionnel la
loi est suspendue les juges ont un mois
pour se prononcer et donc si le Conseil
consuel valide la loi est-ce que la
réforme s'applique définitivement sans
autre recours possible ça serait oublié
une autre arme que peuvent utiliser les
oppositions écouter la socialisme
Valérie Rabault si la loi est promulguée
et en application elle s'applique mais
avant sa promulgation puisque c'est ça
qui compte il peut y avoir d'autres
étapes et je pense notamment au
référendum d'initiative partagée le rip
le référendum d'initiative partagé c'est
une procédure qui date de 2008 elle est
prévue par l'article 11 de la
Constitution il s'agit d'une arme assez
difficile à manier puisqu'il faut qu'un
cinquième des membres du Parlement
prennent l'initiative d'une proposition
de loi prévoyant par exemple de limiter
à 62 l'âge de départ à la retraite le
texte va ensuite être signé par un
dixième des électeurs dans les 9 mois ça
correspond à plus de 4 millions de
Français enfin si et seulement si cette
condition est remplie le texte est un
référendum on est là en terre
complètement inconnue Thomas car jamais
jusqu'à présent la procédure on est allé
jusque là on suit vraiment qu'avec
attention le comptage des signatures
puisqu'on a appris qu'un RIP avait
effectivement été déposé aujourd'hui par
le député communiste Stéphane peu merci
beaucoup Steve pour toutes ces
informations le 1/10 des électeurs c'est
4 millions 870 000 Français
leur salvats en neuf mois ça semble pas
insurmontable mais bon comme le disait
Steve ça n'a jamais été fait ça demande
quoi une organisation une campagne de
communication enfin bon parce que il y a
sans doute 5 millions de Français qui
sont hostiles à la réforme et qui sont
prêts à essayer d'obtenir un référendum
je ne pense pas beaucoup de mouillé en
disant ça visiblement il y en a beaucoup
plus mais effectivement ensuite il y a
toute une organisation et puis c'est pas
la même chose effectivement d'exprimer
une opinion déjà sur une réforme après
d'aller voter un référendum quand on
sait auprès de signer de donner sa
signature quand on sait l'impact et les
conséquences que ça va avoir aussi donc
là à nouveau on entre dans une zone
d'ombre absolue en fait c'est à dire que
très compliqué de de
d'amalgamer différentes situations
on a ce qu'on a parlé de tous les
instruments institutionnels mais il y a
quand même un dernier élément qu'on
appelle voter jusque là c'est la
mobilisation sociale tout ce week-end de
vendredi samedi dimanche jusqu'à ce soir
place Vauban il y avait des
manifestations demain l'intersyndicale
appelle la méditation place de la
République jeudi la journée de grève etc
le durcissement de la mobilisation
c'était un peu ma question est-ce que ça
fait mais c'est très bien est-ce que
est-ce que ça ça peut amener Emmanuel
Macron finalement à renoncer quoi à ne
pas appliquer cette réforme donc je veux
dire quelque chose qui fâche parce que
je le dis depuis plusieurs mois mais
Emmanuel Macron nous a habitué à quand
même des une manière de fonctionner qui
est un peu particulière voire un peu
dangereuse début du quinquennat
précédent à quoi décide-t-il de renoncer
après des violences aéroports de
Notre-Dame-des-Landes après des
phénomènes de violence entre policiers
et manifestants jadis la deuxième fois
où manuel renonce c'est au moment des
gilets jaunes au plus haut de la
mobilisation les fameuse dégradation sur
l'Arc de Triomphe les violences qui en
est mal les images qui font le tour du
monde Emmanuel Macron finit finalement
par renoncer après les phénomènes de
violence donc qu'est-ce qui dit qu'elle
envoie message envoie Emmanuel Macron je
dis pas que c'est moi qui l'ai légitime
ça c'est c'est le même le message de la
macronie c'est à dire que il finit par
écouter le son du peuple à partir du
moment où il y a des des débordements à
partir du moment où il y a des violences
donc je trouve qu'il y a quelque chose
de dangereux à aller aussi loin dans le
risque qui est pris par Emmanuel Macron
et son gouvernement dans les
possibilités de débordement et peut-être
le souhaitent-ils d'ailleurs que non pas
qu'il y a des violences peut-être ne
souhaitent-ils que les syndicats soient
débordés et que comme le disent beaucoup
de commentateurs que peut-être l'opinion
publique finira par décrocher finalement
du soutien qu'il a la mobilisation si ce
pari est celui d'Emmanuel Macron je
trouve que c'est très périlleux Pascal
Perino on se projette le premier
septembre prochain c'est la date prévue
pour l'entrée en vigueur de cette
réforme des retraites vous dites quoi
vous dites elle sera elle sera elle sera
voilà elle sera appliquée ou
emmanuellement on va renoncer
je ne prononcerai pas mais je vous
demande de vous mouiller situation
de retraite depuis 93 je vous répondrai
oui elle s'applique à chaque fois ça il
y a une fronde et puis ça s'applique
mais il est vrai que la coalition la
coalescence des colères qui sont pas
d'ailleurs simplement sur les retraites
mais sur l'inflation les inquiétudes sur
la situation géopolitique
la précovie de tout ça ça fait
énormément et donc on est dans une
situation un peu exceptionnelle même
parmi par rapport à toutes les crises
précédentes donc il peut y avoir
l'option Chirac c'est à dire on retire
parce que voilà on s'aperçoit que sa
déstabilise tellement le régime que ça
n'est peut-être pas la peine d'aller
plus loin ou alors on choisit le moment
pour dramatiser dis
mais détacher de la motion de son tout
de suite pas tout de suite dissolution
c'est ce que le fait le général de
Gaulle après la crise de Mai 68 puis il
pense à l'option du référendum puis il
sera bas sur la dissolution et ça sera
le bon choix pour lui bien sûr et puis
il peut y avoir aussi la dramatisation
suprême c'est à dire la démission du
président ça se pratique très peu
surtout que lui il ne peut pas se
représenter évidemment il en est à son
deuxième mandat il y a un terme Mathieu
que les Américains utilisent pour
qualifier le président quand il a perdu
les élections de mi-mandat c'est le
canard boiteux et est-ce que est-ce que
Emmanuel Macron est un peu condamné à
être un canard boiteux jusqu'à la fin de
ce quinquennat si la situation reste en
état c'est compliqué mais il a encore
des armes on le disait tout à l'heure on
se demandait tout à l'heure ce qui était
le macronisme c'est vrai qu'il y a pas
d'hommes il y a pas de partie il y a pas
de lui il y a surtout pas de doctrine
parce que le mercredi c'est un
pragmatisme donc
s'embarrasse pas de catéchisme un prix
et réciter tout pendant toute une vie
politique on raisonne en fonction des
situations on peut être un coup très
étatique un coup très libéral un coup
très protecteur un coup très menaçant
voilà donc moi je pense que l'animal
politique Emmanuel Macron qui est un
pragmatique utilisera la meilleure arme
possible pour tenter de rebondir le
pourra-t-il ça c'est toute la question
mais il n'est pas encore tout à fait
dans cette situation de du président
américain en fin de mandat et quelque
chose qui est étonnant d'ailleurs c'est
que pour l'instant les appétits de
succession ne sont pas encore
manifestées bruyamment vous prenez
quelqu'un comme Édouard Philippe dont on
se demande ce qu'il fige dans sa mairie
du Havre à part lire et écrire un jour
il va falloir qu'il parle cet homme-là
vous prenez à droite c'est à Laurent
Wauquiez qui lui est planqué dans sa
région auvergre-alpes et qui se tait il
y a aussi un moment où elle doit parler
cet homme là s'il veut avoir des des
vues sur 2027 donc voilà on est dans une
espèce de pour le l'allon de l'âge de la
retraite ils sont pas trop sortis du
bois un peu figé ou ou il n'est pas
empêché encore le président de la
République mais il va devoir
manifestement faire quelque chose pour
débloquer les situations dissolution en
maniement on verra mais en tout cas ils
voient un geste fort alors vous m'offrez
une transition pour le dernier chapitre
de ce de ce débat on va parler des LR
puisque
49-3 l'émotion de censure laisse des
traces au sein du parti lrpublicain on
écoute justement à ce propos
Jean-François Copé le maire de mots
c'était sur notre antenne vendredi c'est
la responsabilité de quelques députés
républicains qui se sont trouvés en
nombre suffisant pour pour obliger en
réalité un à ce 49-3 pour la sécurité et
l'intérêt supérieur du pays mais deux
surtout qui ont par ces choix personnels
en réalité
fracturé gravement ce qui constitue la
marque de fabrique des républicains qui
est celle d'être un parti de
gouvernement par opposition à des
parties extrémistes populiste qu'est-ce
qui est la marque d'un parti de
gouvernement qui soit de centre droit au
centre gauche ou de droite ou de gauche
par opposition à l'extrême droite ou
l'extrême gauche c'est que c'est un
parti qui est capable de prendre des
mesures qui peuvent être impopulaires
sur le moment si c'est l'intérêt
supérieur du pays
alors ça va comment les LR sont perçus
par l'opinion après effectivement ces
lignes de fractures qu'on a vu elles
étaient rappelées par Jean-François Copé
mais même entre les députés et les
sénateurs LR on l'a bien commenté ici au
sein même du groupe LR à l'Assemblée
comment c'est perçu parce que lui il dit
attention on est en train de perdre
notre identité de partie de gouvernement
c'est un peu ce que ce que ce que nous
dit Jean-François
parce que je crois que malgré tout ils
ont pas réussi à justement imprimer un
nouveau projet pour la société française
il y a un problème de
personnalisation d'incarnation du
pouvoir Éric Ciotti finalement qui
rassemble quand même pas toutes les voix
au sein des DLR donc effectivement il
est très fragilisé ce parti est très
fragilisée et puis surtout ce qui a
quelque chose quand même qui est très
nouveau pour un parti traditionnel c'est
qu'il y ait des voies dissonantes et là
on voit qu'effectivement ça va me dire
il y a des bah finalement tout le monde
ne vote pas derrière le derrière le
parti et derrière le président donc dans
l'opinion c'est c'est un peu perturbant
c'est ce qui se passe aujourd'hui au
niveau au niveau des partis politiques
c'est plutôt quelque chose ailleurs que
les Français attendaient cet
individualisation quelque part aussi de
la politique c'est à dire que un député
ben finalement va pas forcément voter
comme un seul bloc derrière un parti et
va à un moment donné
avoir une voix un petit peu dissonante
mais on voit que ça a des limites quand
même en termes de fonction de
fonctionnement de la démocratie parce
que dans ce cas là effectivement c'est
extrêmement difficile notamment pour
Éric Ciotti bah de d'avoir une vision
très claire de la de la ligne si
derrière on le sait pas en fait Pascal
Perrino est-ce que vous iriez jusqu'à
dire que ce parti est menacé d’implosion
aujourd'hui ah oui de manière de manière
claire et éventuellement de
marginalisation absolue on l'avait bien
vu avec le Parti socialiste c'est la
première le premier parti porteur d'une
culture de gouvernement qui se
marginalise complètement jusqu'à ce que
ça candidate fasse moins de 2% des
suffrages exprimés et LR avait évité ça
dans un premier temps et ne parvient
plus à l'éviter LR est en train en effet
de ne suis plus à quel saint se vouer il
n'a plus de leader capable d'imposer
allez que tout le monde aille dans le
même sens c'est très rare mais au moins
qu'il y ait une hégémonie de la
direction là c'est fini c'est quand même
la tradition politique de de secours il
y avait un certain culte du chef là il y
a plus aucun chef qui est respecté et
chacun joue sa partition personnelle
monsieur Pradier même s'est fait sa
marque de fabrique c'est j'existe
personnellement bon ça va être difficile
à tenir sur la très longue période mais
c'est ça ça marque de fabrique donc en
effet
elle est en peu à peu de quitter la
scène s'il continue à filer ce coton
mais ce qui est très inquiétant c'est
que les forces politiques porteuses de
culture de gouvernement sont en train de
disparaître et classer séduction
populiste au fond donc parlait
Jean-François Copé et très forte à
gauche on l'a vu avec la nupesse qui a
imposé le la à tout ce qui reste de la
gauche écologiste et socialiste et
communiste et puis maintenant on le voit
à droite on le voit à droite au fond le
populisme de droite touche maintenant
toute une partie des républicains qui
sont très loin au fond de personnalités
comme l'homme qui représente un peu le
centre de gravité jusque là de la droite
française à savoir le président du Sénat
Gérard Larcher donc là on est très très
loin de de la grande tradition
républicaine des LR pierre Jacquemin
pour un Emmanuel Macron qui a essayé là
de construire une autorité autour de la
réforme des retraites avec les LR il y
avait il y a eu des textes qui ont été
votés avec des voix de gauche ou des
écologistes précédemment est-ce que vous
pensez qu'il est encore en capacité de
construire comme ça au cas par cas parce
que c'est c'était la leçon du soir des
législatives ça mon sentiment c'est
qu'il y a beaucoup d'hypocrisie quand
même et que on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui
a priori il y a assez peu de raison qui
serait justifié pour ne pas voir aboutir
un programme de coalition comme le
suggère aujourd'hui effectivement
Nicolas Sarkozy et
Rachida Dati c'est-à-dire que le
logiciel je crois aujourd'hui DLR et a
totalement compatible avec le programme
d'Emmanuel Macron y compris d'ailleurs
quand les LR vont sur le terrain du
rassemblement national sur les questions
d'asile et d'immigration Emmanuel Macron
le premier volet Asie l'immigration
était quand même déjà très dur lors de
son premier quinquennat il fait un
tournant sur notre tradition de l'asile
le tradition d'accueil donc je crois
vraiment qu'il y a une forme
d'hypocrisie parce que pour moi Emmanuel
Macron est profondément de droite
profondément alors vous qualifier de
pragmatique et moi je qualifie plutôt de
néolibéral autoritaire Emmanuel Macron
mais je pense que c'est tout cette
famille là aux révocation à se réunir
donc je pense que peut-être la planète
petite fenêtre de tir que peuvent avoir
les républicains c'est la fin du
macronisme d'ailleurs que cette famille
peut se réunir si elle réussit à trouver
un projet politique qui renoue avec la
tradition un peu plus sociale un peu
moins autoritaire que ne l'est
aujourd'hui la droite peut être telle
qu'elle est tracée par Emmanuel Macron
mais on a parlé d'hypocrisie
d'incohérence mais les incohérences ce
sont exprimés de partout il y a eu
autant de droites qu'il n'y avait de
parlementaires et je dis bien
parlementaire parce qu'il y avait autant
de droits de différentes au Sénat et à
l'Assemblée nationale et en même temps
on a reproché à Aurélien Pradier d'avoir
soutenu une candidate qui prenait la
retraite à 65 ans et de s'être absolu de
d'avoir voté contre l'aurait voté contre
si ça avait été présenté à l'assemblée
et en même temps je me souviens
d'Olivier Marleix disant je ne serai pas
nous ne serons pas complices d'une
méthode brutale bon bah pardon mais
après là le gouvernement fait la
démonstration des méthodes brutales donc
même devrait dire aujourd'hui nous ne
pouvons pas soutenir un texte qui passe
de manière aussi durement
un mot de conclusion puisque je voulais
dire on enregistre cette émission en fin
d'après-midi on vient d'avoir le
résultat de la motion de censure et elle
est rejetée mais à neuf fois prêt parce
qu'elle Périne en effet dire c'est dire
la fragilité quand même présidentielle
c'est que vous suggérer tout à l'heure
je pense s'impose et c'est plus étroit
que les calculs qui étaient prévus on se
disait il y aura une marge de vin ben
voilà 9 c'est la moitié de la marge qui
était prévue ce qui montre que la
mauvaise humeur n'est pas simplement
dans le pays la mauvaise humeur est
également dans la présentation
parlementaire et parmi il faudra
regarder en détail parmi des forces qui
d'ailleurs peut-être ont un moment
soutenu Emmanuel Macron il y a des
dissidences qui maintenant vont jusqu'au
cœur de la macronie et donc il est
urgent que le vrai chef de la majorité à
savoir le président de la République
redonne un cap et puis
face baisser l'inquiétude des Français
parce que les conseils n'ont pas envie
de la chier en ligne comme disait le
Général de Gaulle ils ont envie de de
concevoir collectivement une porte de
sortie et ils savent très bien que le
président même lorsque c'était manuel
Macron est un de ceux qui peut leur
proposer une porte de sortie on verra ce
qui peut nous inventer dans les
prochains jours merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce premier débat